After this brief diversion, let's get back to
the actual deduction process.
When you are reasoning what could have happened in a program,
we again see the program execution as a succession of states.
And then we reason backwards from what we
observe to what could have happened beforehand.
This reasoning, this backwards reasoning
is actually structured along the ways that earlier
events in the program could have influenced later events.
The most important concept when
reasoning backwards is called data dependency.
The idea is as follows:
We do have 2 statements, say A and B in the program,
and now A writes a variable,
which is later read by B.
In our example up here, A may have written this variable,
and this will then be read by B.
Then we say that these 2 statements are data dependent on each other.
B is data dependent on A
because there is a flow of data
from the statement A to the statement B.
This concept of data dependency allows us
to trace back the possible locations in the state
as well as the statements that cause them
back within the program execution and therefore
to isolate the possible causes for an infection
and later the failure.